[Music]
good evening at welcome to tucker
carlson tonight as washington fusses
over the russia hoax for a third year in
a row a lot of other things are
happening that don't get the attention
they deserve for example the big tech
companies have launched their fiercest
attack yet on your right as an American
to follow your conscience and to say
what you believe unlike earlier
generations of authoritarians the tech
muggles don't say any of this out loud
they're not honorable enough to state
their intentions clearly instead they'd
rape censorship in the soothing banality
of HR department cliches listen here to
Mark Zuckerberg explained that the death
of free speech in America is actually a
really positive thing that we all need
to get behind we're taking a more
proactive role and making sure that all
of our partners and developers use our
services for good we're very focused on
making sure that our recommendations and
discovery surfaces aren't highlighting
groups where people are repeatedly
sharing misinformation or harmful
content and we're working hard to
completely remove groups if they exist
primarily due to violate our policies or
or do things that are dangerous who knew
fascism could be so chirpy groups that
do things that are dangerous what does
happen does that mean dangerous like
hurting other people or dangerous as in
saying things that Mark Zuckerberg
doesn't like or considers bad for
business well yesterday we found out
Facebook released its latest enemies
list Alex Jones Milo innopolis Paul
Joseph Watson Louis Farrakhan Laura
boomer all of them were designated
dangerous individuals and banned from
Facebook and from its subsidiary
Instagram Alex Jones this company in
fours was banned as well and described
as a dangerous organization didn't
explain exactly how how dangerous is
Infowars well Facebook believes it's so
dangerous that you can be banned from
using the platform Facebook just for
sharing its content unless you
simultaneously denounce it let that
penetrate for just one moment think
about it just for a second
Mark Zuckerberg is not simply censoring
opinions he's prescribing which
political opinions you're allowed to
have
which conversations all of us in this
country can have about America keep in
mind that nobody voted for Mark
Zuckerberg he's 34 years old he's
completely cut off from reality he's
worth seventy two billion dollars and
yet he can single-handedly make our
First Amendment irrelevant after two
hundred and fifty years here's the most
amazing thing of all our media think
that's great
now journalists are supposed to defend
free speech you would think that was
their job since they make a living from
it but when corporate America issues an
order when Mark Zuckerberg says jump
their question is how high mr.
Zuckerberg listen to them celebrate Mark
Zuckerberg and sell you out completely
why are they doing this now well it's a
good question as to why they waited this
long but so Alex Jones has been banned
from Facebook for a long period of time
but now they banned him they banned his
like little underling Paul Joseph Watson
now that they kick them off the platform
that's great for now but it doesn't roll
back the clock you have also excesses in
the First Amendment and the Second
Amendment right now you know I don't
think that the fourth of the forefathers
said well you can say yeah you know all
sorts of hateful things and spread it
around the world literally spread it
through the internet I have no issue
with it at all
I want them shut down I want them
silenced I want them muted I think they
are horrible for our society I want them
shut down
I want them silenced I want them muted
but don't worry
these people aren't terrifying or
anything don't kid yourself it's not
just Alex Jones they want silence muted
shut down
recently the Poynter Institute which is
a nonprofit that's supposed to support
journalism put out a list of what they
called unreliable news outlets can you
imagine unreliable self-awareness in
short supply in the journalism business
but pointer crafted this list with the
help of the Southern Poverty Law Center
she can imagine who made the list the
Washington free beacon the Daily Caller
the daily signal the Washington Examiner
basically everyone who's not CNN or
MSNBC or precisely aligned with their
politics pointer called for advertisers
to blacklist and therefore bankrupt
these news outlets
their fellow progressives applauded as
far as they're concerned this is total
war what we're watching out in real time
is this country become unfree so the
question is who exactly is defending us
in all of this us who might dissent from
Mark Zuckerberg view or think that NBC
News maybe doesn't tell the whole truth
all the time or don't trust Mark
Zuckerberg to control what we think what
about us who's standing up for us where
our leaders in Congress where's the
White House nowhere
as long as big tech is in hassling them
personally indirectly as long as their
accounts remain open they don't seem to
care they're fools well any of these
people get reelected in a country where
left-wing tech companies control the
terms of political debate can you really
win a presidential election if Google
opposes you no you can't not a chance
not right now
without free speech there is no
democracy it's time to stop lying about
that